[keys clacking]
[mouse clicks, email swooshes]
- [sighs]
[sips]
- Hey, Matt.
Got your email
with the report.
Thanks so much
for sending.
Question:
did you CC John on that?
- Uh, yes.
I believe I did.
- Oh, that's interesting,
'cause I'm looking
at that email right now,
and you didn't.
- Oh.
- You BCC'd me.
Uh...
You still got the email then,
right?
- I did.
- Look.
I know you're new around here,
so I just want to
make sure that you understand
the email protocol.
You always CC both John and I
on all work emails,
'cause if you BCC him,
then I can't check
to make sure
that you CC'd him, hmm?
- Got it.
I made a mistake.
- Great.
Question: why did you
make that mistake?
- Um...
I guess I'm a little tired
this morning.
- Aww, gosh.
- Uh-huh.
Why are you so tired?
- I have anxiety that sometimes
keeps me up at night.
- What causes this anxiety?
- I guess sometimes
I feel like this can be
sort of a confrontational
work environment.
- Hey, bud,
Hampton DeVille encourages
aggressive
confrontational criticism.
- Why don't you
like confrontation?
Defend your position.
- Oh.
Uh...
No, I mean, I think
confrontation is a good thing.
It's just sometimes
confrontation
hurts my job performance
and damages
my personal wellbeing.
- Uh-oh; well, if you can't
manage your emotions, Matt,
what makes you think
you're qualified
to manage people
at this company?
- Honestly, I don't know.
- Oh.
- I never really
saw myself here.
I mean, after college,
I volunteered for a program
teaching underprivileged kids
because I wanted to help people,
but then one of the students
stabbed me,
and the school was pretty dirty
and I just relaized
I wasn't cut out for it.
So I moved back in
with my parents,
which, I'm pretty sure
led to them getting a divorce,
because that's what
they told me happened.
Then I worked a series of jobs
that eventually landed me here,
where I'm just a cog
in a soulless corporate machine,
and I'm not--
- Okay, well,
just make sure that you CC
both John and I
on all work emails.
It's a simple mistake,
but it's just important
to follow protocol.
- Yes.
Jake, question:
why do you think it's okay
to come in to work
with your shirt untucked?
- Because life is meaningless,
and nothing we do matters.
- Okay, great.
- Have a great day, you two.
- Thanks, guys.
[rock music]
♪ ♪
[manic laughter]
- Hampton DeVille has emerged
as one of the largest,
most profitable corporations
in the world,
with over 300,000 employees
internationally,
their footprint
stretches across the globe.
Under the leadership
of their CEO Christian DeVille,
they've become market leaders
in everything
from agricultural goods
to pharmaceuticals,
from household appliances
to industrial weaponry.
You've probably
heard their slogan.
Hampton DeVille:
we make everything.
But now they are attempting
to muscle their way
up the highly competitive
tech industry.
Today marks the launch
of the Obelisk,
Hampton DeVille's
touch screen tablet
which boasts a screen
eight times the size
of the iPad.
But that launch
may be in jeopardy
after an insensitive tweet
was sent out
from Hampton DeVille's
twitter account earlier today.
As Hurricane Letisha continues
to devastate the Gulf Coast,
Hampton DeVille tweeted,
"Was your house blown away
by Hurricane Letisha?
"Pick up the Obelisk
to follow hurricane news.
You'll be blown away
by the size."
In response
to the offensive tweet,
the Internet is calling for
a boycott of the Obelisk.
[blade shings]
- [grunts]
[metallic clang, heavy thud]
[grunts]
[suspenseful music
builds dramatically]
♪ ♪
- Do you think we're gonna
get to eat anything today?
- Don't count on it.
There's a rigid
food hierarchy here.
Executives get first pick,
then junior executives,
then us, the junior executives
in training.
- $500 billion corporation.
and they never have enough
bagels for everyone.
- Why didn't you eat breakfast
before work?
- I didn't have time.
I hit the snooze button
15 times this morning,
which is a new record that
I'm actually kind of proud of.
Did you eat anything?
- No.
I'm trying to
watch my figure.
I want to have a hot body
'cause I'm tired of
developing my personality.
- Yeah, I've been there.
- Yum.
I love eclairs.
- Oh, my god.
This is so good.
I'm gonna take two.
- Aggressive.
Confident.
I like that you're not afraid
to take what you want.
[both munching and moaning]
- Damn it.
There's only two bagels left.
- Whoa, have you seen this tweet
the company sent out?
The Internet is freaking out
about it.
- "You'll be blown away
by the size"?
Jesus Christ.
We're living
inside of a nightmare.
[eerie ominous music]
♪ ♪
- Why in the [bleep]
is everyone
standing around eating bagels
while we are being crucified
on the Internet?
Spit out those bagels!
We have work to do!
[ominous music continues]
♪ ♪
[metallic crashing]
- No!
Sorry.
- Everyone in this room,
look to your left.
Now...
look to your right.
100% of those people
are ruining my [bleep] day.
- Look, that one over there's
still good.
I'm gonna get it
after the meeting.
- Yeah,
but there's no cream cheese.
- [whispers]
On the wall over there.
- Into developing the Obelisk,
and now its success
is being threatened
by a [bleep] tweet.
♪ ♪
[bleep] you.
- I wish I could be
more like Christian.
- Why? He acts like
a complete psychopath
and nobody stands up to him.
- Exactly.
He fought his way to the top,
and now he gets to treat people
like they're
his personal service dogs.
- If I ever get to the top,
I'm gonna at least
make sure everyone
gets a goddamn bagel.
- Don't worry.
You'll be corrupted by power.
That's part of growing up.
- I want to tell you a story.